squirrels squirrels and depending on how
you feel about them you may be thinking
yay these lovely cute little critters or
you may be thinking of rats with fluffy
Tails but however you feel about them
I'm gonna be talking about the maths of
species conflict there are two species
of squirrel in Britain there's the red
and the gray and the gray have
supplanted the red and pushed them out
primarily up to Scotland and some
there's Parts in in North Wales
dominantly if you see a squirrel in the
UK it's going to be a great squirrel so
how do we understand that well we try
and write down interaction equations
between the two squirrel populations
we're going to be looking at the gray
squirrel and the red squirrel population
and we're going to write down some
equations that tell us how they interact
Grace girl population changes with time
so T is going to be time the red
population is going to be changing over
time now we can include space in this
and understand how they were pushed
further north and further north but
generally we don't really need to we if
you're considering an island we can just
consider how that conflict occurs so
we'll we'll throw away space for now and
just consider an island of gray and red
squirrels and what we say is that the
gray squirrels undergo binary
competition as do the red squirrels in
fact the equations I'm going to write
are going to be pretty damn similar so
all this says is that the population of
squirrels grows proportional to how many
squirrels there are but if there are too
many squirrels they compete
and that could be for resources Partners
homes
nuts can be here for anything but
there's some competition keeping their
population finite same with the red
exactly the same but we're going to add
in a new term and we're going to add in
Alpha gr here and beta gr here minus
Alpha gr is the competition of the gray
and the red for the gray squirrels B to
gr is the competition for the gray and
red squirrels for the red it's how they
interact so it's always going to be a
negative effect the competition is never
going to help the species but the size
of Alpha and beta are going to be how
good they are at competing now that's a
lot of maths I fully understand that but
one thing I love about mathematical
biology is that you get so far and so
much information from drawing pictures I
if you can you know a picture is worth a
thousand words and so if you can draw a
picture that immediately shows the
answer to these equations you can
convince parliament of policy makers to
how to save the red squirrel so what
we're going to do is we need to
understand a little idea called a null
Cline the null clients in this are where
the populations aren't changing okay so
when we set these to zero that's when
the null client is so we set this left
hand side to zero we have some
conditions linking the red and green red
and green the red and gray which will
give us some curves and they are the
north lines so in this first case here
we have G
equals zero when G is equal to zero that
will be satisfied or we could have one
minus G minus Alpha R equals zero when g
t equals zero that's the gray squirrel
milk line this one if R is zero that's
also satisfied we could have one minus r
minus b g equals and that's the red
squirrel alkaline now what we can do is
rearrange these and what we find is if
we put gray is the dominant population
we can rearrange this to one minus Alpha
R and this one would be then G is equal
to one minus r over beta okay so they're
just two lines so I have four and all
kinds two for each population one g
equals zero and g equals one minus Alpha
R for the gray squirrels R equals zero
and g equals one minus r over beta the
red squirrels okay lines so g equals
zero is a fantastic line to draw as is R
equals zero and these are just two lines
connecting G and r g and R well there
are different ways that these lines can
cross understanding how the cross
predict what will happen with these
populations you can do all this analysis
particularly you can work it out with
numbers and show that all of this is
concrete but when you can draw pictures
why would you do that so I'm going to be
looking at my population uh in terms of
two axes we're going to have the red
population along the x-axis and the gray
squirrel along the y-axis you'll notice
that these lines are negative so as I
increase r g decreases so for the gray
squirrels we have g equals zero so this
is one nullcline along there GT equals
zero and the other line is somewhere
don't really care it's just a line now
for the red squirrels we have R equals
zero that's up here and then again
another line but does my line cross like
that does it cross like that does it
cross there or does it cross like that
there are four different cases we have
to consider and they each tell us
something different about what could
happen this one is the red squirrels
along there is zero and so let's put the
red nullcline underneath the gray
squirrels and along that line r dot is
equal to zero I'll quickly explain this
a DOT can stand for RT just a simple way
so I don't have to keep writing T and so
along here we have g dot equals zero now
we could we could draw lots of more
detail on here but from this setup of
the noklines
the G is dominating the Dynamics and the
other thing we can say is where is the
system going to go I will pick a point
in here and that will be a setup of the
system the system under these equations
will drive that trajectory to a place
where it will stop moving where could it
go well if it stops moving then both the
Reds stop moving in time and the gray
stop moving in time so where are the
Reds and a black line cross that's a
potential place where this trajectory
could end up okay so there are three
places it could end up it could end up
at zero zero that's the case when my red
and gray populations are extinct it
could end up here that's where my great
population is extinct in my red survive
it could end up here my red Hideout but
my gray has survived and in this setup
of the naught lines it's actually the
gray that's going to dominate so all of
my trajectories are going to end up
being pushed towards this one and the
reason comes from this line being the
first one out it's dominating the system
the gray squirrels are out competing the
red okay and that's why this line is
furthest out right so let's that's one
setup we could have of these knocklines
the the gray line does not have to be
the first one out because the red line
is furthest out so the guess what the
red squirrels will dominate and they
will head to the steady state why don't
we ever stop at zero zero because
there's a positive population uh four so
no matter how small your population
start they will grow so what we say is
this is an unstable equilibrium if we
have no squirrels to start with we never
will
but any small amount of squirrels will
pushes away so it's really these two
that we have to worry about so what will
happen here is the population will tend
to this one it's because that the red
milk line is furthest out so the reds
are dominating the system they're out
competing degrees now okay it tells us
that can happen but that's obviously not
the case that's happening in the UK
unfortunately again that's not the only
two ways that this could happen what's
another way that they could cross where
we could have gray squirrel milkline
there and the red squirrel milkline
there this is one of the interesting
cases because again you'll have the
cases of everything extinct red extinct
gray extinct but now they're Crossing at
a new point we didn't have previously so
we have a fourth solution and now in
this setup we actually find that this
state here is stable it's attractive
because there's no dominant pairing we
don't kill off either of them they can
actually survive in harmony so the
trajectories will push the populations
here again unfortunately not how the UK
is working out so what we can say what's
happening in this case is Alpha and beta
in our equations initially are small we
could we can say that because what's
really happening is they're not really
competing we could take this to a limit
and say Alpha and beta are zero they're
really not competing at all they're
living together
but they're each doing their own thing
and in that case what you find is they
quite happily live together you have
your nuts I'll have mine and we'll all
live happily families small competition
what happens when competition is Big
well this gives us our fourth case so
there's the gray squirrel and this is
the red squirrel again we have that
fourth one but we've swapped the Nook
line so we have the the there and our
fourth one because we've swapped the
Nook lines we are now in the case when
the competition is very big both are
trying their best and in this case the
steady state isn't stable anymore it's
unstable so in this case we have the
Four Points again that we're going to
head to but this time it's pushing us
away from the state so our population
out here will push us to the case where
the red has died out and if we start out
here it will push to the case where the
gray is died out and again if we start
with a small batch of both we'll be
sucked in now which one will we choose
all depends on where we start so it's a
very hard thing you need to know what
your setup is to know where will the red
win out or will the gray win out now of
course in Britain unfortunately we are
in this case here where the Grays are
easily dominating the Reds and the Grays
are winning out but from that piece of
mathematics we get to see the whole idea
of what biology can produce we can
produce cases where you're interacting
peacefully you're interacting
aggressively you're out trying to
occupet each other you're trying to
out-compete each other separately that
one of the cases that you're not even
trying you know your the grades are
really winning over the Reds here the
reds are winning out of the Grays but
through that one equation we can see the
entire entire plane of all mathematical
competitive you said we're now in this
situation here is it possible it started
in that situation there though oh yeah I
mean the grades have always dominated
the Reds they're they're better Hunters
they're bigger they're more aggressive
so to but the question is could we ever
move it to say this or perhaps you know
do if we want to eradicate the gray I'm
going to sit on the fence I I love all
animals but do we want to a rabbit
eradicate the gray or do we want to
allow them to live in harmony
well in that case that tells you exactly
what you need to do you need to change
the Dynamics you need to change their
competitive abilities either you swap
them all clients around you make the
Reds more aggressive in some way or you
move it such that they don't compete you
give them two different food sources
okay Grays love sausages and the Reds
love peanut butter if you could find
something like that then they could both
survive and be happy but unfortunately
just because we can say how it can work
doesn't mean it's possible to push us in
this direction Tom some of this kind of
feels like just kind of stuff that's
quite obvious and intuitive and you've
really complicated and formalized it
with graphs and equations where I could
have told you the Grays are better
hunters and therefore why do you need
this mathematical formalism for things
that seem intuitively obvious when you
think about them yep no a it gives you a
way of framing that argument because
there are a lot of arguments and you
could say Gray's a better Hunters okay
well is that the reason I haven't put
the fact that they're hunt the better
hunters in here I've said that they
compete better in the Reds that could be
for mating reasons it could be for a
roost where they live all I'm saying is
they're competing better so you've
specified one point I've taken out a
strategy another thing it gives us is
being able to see well how can we what
is the strategy space that we're working
in you again have said okay the Grays of
one out that's the case we're dealing in
that doesn't tell us how we get to the
Grays and res living together or the
Reds surviving
this comes down to a question about the
pandemic that's happening a lot why do
we need mathematical modelers we can see
how many people are ill we can see how
many people are dying we've got the data
that's true but it doesn't tell us what
the best route of getting out of this
mess is and that's what Mass Gives You
it gives a rigorous framework of
language to understand of being in one
situation how do I get to another
thanks to Jane Street for supporting
this episode now Jane Street's a top
research-based trading firm it has
offices all around the world including
New York
London
Hong Kong
Singapore
and Amsterdam one of the reasons they
support number file besides just loving
math-based videos is Jane Street hopes a
few of you may end up working with them
go to their website click here on join
Jane Street to find out about all the
great jobs internships and opportunities
they have on offer I visited one of
their offices last week and trust me
this is a place you'd really enjoy
working it was one of the most amazing
workplaces I've ever seen go to
janestreet.com find out what's going on
if you do end up working there hey tell
them number files sent you
okay and from this what you get is a
relation between time and first
interaction and that's proportional to
how far away you are from them space is
being exit and the rate of diffusion